I really want to start with congrats
I've seen the whole series and uh it has
stayed with me since I watched
um I really want to just say great job
to all three of you thank you so much
thank you so there's like a million
things to talk about but I'm curious
um how long did it actually take from
when you decided to make this to write
this these episodes because the ambition
that is on display and the scale and
scope of this series is really really
hard to pull off you think
I this had been percolating inside of me
for a very long time
um certainly at least since An
Inconvenient Truth where I felt like
okay this is what a documentary can do
but as a scripted Storyteller I felt
there was more to explore
um and that if you can escape the
confines of what it what what a doc asks
you and explore the larger world of
Storytelling and scripted storytelling
that we could begin to look at these
stories in in new ways and could you
take stories
um from from the past like a thriller a
love story
um you know a family drama comedy could
you take those and move them into the
future and just change the climate and
then how does that affect the characters
and the action you know this will sound
a little bit esoteric but I know you so
I feel like say this
um you know the the decalogue had a huge
influence on me and what I saw what
Kozlowski could do with the Ten
Commandments I thought is there a way of
doing storytelling around climate change
that did discrete stories that were
interconnected episode I don't want to
speak spoilers at all but episode 6
broke me I was such a
it's a heartbreaking episode
um uh talk but one of the things about
that is you guys invented all this new
jargon if you will and had to display
these new technologies in this new
future so can you talk a little bit
about about putting that together and
the people you Incorporated to help
bring these things to life sure
absolutely
um so
to to back up a little bit the show
takes place over you know over 30 years
in an imagine future starting in 2037 so
when we begin with episode one we wanted
it to really look and feel quite close
to now um it was important to us that it
wasn't technologically alienating that
people weren't just you know Moon boots
and space cars
um that it felt you know close to home
um But as time goes on you know we get
farther from the present day and so the
technology and the future get a little
farther from what we're doing
um right now so by episode six we had
the freedom to really go kind of in some
fun and crazy directions imagining
potential Futures potential Futures
because of how bad climate change will
be how bad the effects of it will be and
what that'll do to Human Relationships
so Sarah Nolan who wrote that episode
really used her own imagination to
invent these ways that people might
relate to each other and
um think about love and loss and
connection and how people find
connection how people find authenticity
in a world with so many screens and so
many gig workers and
um I really think we were able to create
uh an imagined future that is starting
to feel a little bit further from you
know just around the corner but you can
see the threads that connect it to what
we're all going through today and this
show put together both an amazing group
of experts both on climate on technology
we were fortunate to bring our
Productions uh he was brought on earlier
in the process so there was a whole uh
period where we generate a log concept
art around this
um so that this was meant to be an uh
exciting vision of the future not
restoring you know the stories are light
and dark and Tackle tough stuff
um but we wanted we were consciously
wanted to be uh an original and unique
look at the possible future you might
live in and one that's immersive and so
the audience can you know it's uh it's a
big vast Journey over the episodes and
we wanted them to be able to sit and
enter truly enter this work the world
that Scott and Dorothy created
um and that was um anyway so that it was
it was there was a lot of intention
behind it I would imagine as you guys
mentioned you spoke to many different
leaders to get the data to sort of
incorporate into the series what do you
actually wish more people knew that that
from what you learned to what um sort of
like do you know what I mean like I'm
sure you learned a lot of different
things what do you wish more people knew
that you have now been told I wish more
people knew how much power they have to
impact what the future is going to look
like
um every expert we talked to was really
clear that the difference between a a
1.9 Centigrade temperature rise and a
2.1 Centigrade rise those feel very
different they have very different
consequences so things changes amounts
that can seem teeny tiny you know it can
feel like you're just taking a ruler and
measuring these little incremental
distances and what's the difference
those differences are really vast and we
currently today right now have the
ability to you know put our Collective
hands on the dial and help determine
what that change is going to be
I think there's an impoverishment of
your experience of being alive that
we're on the brink of when I was a kid
you know and I played Little League my
dad would say go get him tiger and I
knew what a tiger was and what happens
when we say that to our children and
there are no more tigers
um and that will happen in our lifetimes
unless we make some very very important
choices
and for me I want people to question the
narratives they've been given that this
is beyond them that the scope of this is
too big for an individual I think the
first thing we have to do is understand
that that is a narrative that oil
companies and the other people who are
really benefiting from the status quo
desperately want us to believe you know
when we get asked questions about well
gee did you take a plane to that
interview
um aren't you a hypocrite well to some
degree these are the choices we have and
to dismiss someone and their
participation and their passion because
their choices don't allow for them to
really express what they wish the world
could be is a kind of paralysis we've
got to overcome and I feel like the show
if it if it does only that if it begins
to make people question the narratives
they're they're walking around with by
by exploring other ones you know that
would be amazing and and look that's
what all of the movies about the Vietnam
war did for me when I was growing up
this is mostly repeating what Scott
Dorothy said the script is not written
it's an it's an extrapolation that's not
the extrapolation right so this is a
possible future and the and
um we can you know we control the future
still you know it's not written and uh
everyone we spoke to uh there are this
can go another way and and a better way
you know and so part of the point making
the show is is by jumping ahead
um you actually can get a handle on the
subject it's very hard we're overwhelmed
by
um uh by the present in so many ways
right now and so by getting a little
outside of it a glimpse into the future
hopefully it gives people an
understanding of what's what's of the
subject of their own life of their own
role in it what it means to them and
there's still a positive future uh
available to us one of the things is I
think it's very easy to when you see on
the news someone talks about oxygen
tanks in the future it's one thing but
when you actually see it depicted on
actors you know
um uh I have to rap but just real quick
talk a little about the fact that
something like this can actually
hopefully impact real people by seeing
it rather than just hearing about it
yeah I think what the show does at its
best is it shows you what does climate
change feel like
you know not not what does it look like
on a graph not what is a chart not as a
number what does it feel like what does
it feel like to be a mom or dad or
partner or friend in a climate changed
world and that is what we wanted
everyone to have a glimpse of is the
internal emotional life that people are
going to go through that we all of us
this is near this is a near future we're
all going to go through what does it
feel like what is it emotionally to go
through that experience on that note I
need to stop I'm just going to say
seriously congrats and I really hope a
ton of people watch this